people with multiple quirks used to be a
really rare thing in my hero academia
but as the series progresses they seem
to be appearing much more frequently
when i first began youtube i made a
video ranking the eight best multiple
quirk users at the time
so today i thought i'd do an updated and
more accurate version
to set the record straight just before
we get into this epic list
there are two brand new original
episodes of my hero academia
coming to crunchyroll on the 15th of
august which
if i've uploaded this on the right day
then that should be today
if you go to crunchyroll.com turtlequirk
you'll get a two-week free trial of
crunchyroll's premium service
where you can watch both of these
episodes for free with no ads
and in 1080p quality the episodes are
not part of season five
but rather it's just something to kind
of hold us over until season five comes
out
i'd also recommend signing up to the
free trial because i mean crunchyroll
have the biggest library of anime and
drama titles that you're gonna find
i recently used their service to catch
up on the first season of dr stone
and if you saw my q a the other week
you'll know this was the first anime to
ever make me cry
real tears i'd ten billion percent
recommend it
i'm also using crunchyroll to catch up
on jojo's bizarre adventure
though i'm currently on part three so no
spoilers in the comments for that guys
new episodes of your favorite anime
always get uploaded to crunchyroll
within
literally a couple of hours of airing in
japan this was the case for my hero
season 4
and will obviously be the case for
season 5 as well so do bear that in mind
as well there are just so many
benefits massive thanks to them for
sponsoring this video
and remember go to crunchyroll.com
turtlequirk
to check out those episodes for free
link in the description and my pinned
comment
okay so starting at eighth place we have
a guy called wolfram who was the main
antagonist
of the first my hero movie this guy had
two quirks in total
one of which was given to him by all for
one however before we get into that i
think it's best to talk about his
natural power
which was metal manipulation this quark
functions in a similar way to cementos
and basically wolfram can manipulate any
metal he makes contact with
which he primarily uses to generate
barriers to protect himself
or metallic pillars in which to crush
his enemies that said
whilst he usually needs to make contact
with the metal we saw that once he used
this quirk amplification device
the power allowed him to draw metal
towards him and manipulate it without
even touching it
he was also able to restrain and hold
back all might with this power-up
although admittedly this wasn't prime
almight but still it was a big feat
nevertheless
the villain named wolfram is a reference
to his quirk as in german it means
tungsten
which until i watched dr stone i didn't
realize tungsten was the strongest metal
on earth but you learn something new
every day
wolfram's second quirk is muscle
augmentation which allowed him to vastly
increase his muscle size
until he was just glowing with strength
this one let him deal serious damage to
the symbol of peace from close range
which is the reason afo gave it to him
overall i say wolfram is a pretty strong
character in this universe
but without the help of the quirk
amplification device i wouldn't really
have him near the top
top tier but you know he still ranked
pretty well for this list however he
comes in
in last place moving on to seventh we
have a character from the vigilante
spin-off manga
known as number six or as he likes to
call himself the high speed hero
o'clock 2. do not let the name for you
though he's still very much a villain
who was killed and tried to kill his
fair share of professional heroes
he firstly has a quirk that allows him
to detonate his body parts at will
delivering powerful explosions and then
regenerating almost immediately
we saw in recent chapters how he chased
the main character of vigilantes down
the street
and his knuckles began to expand in this
panel before giving a punch that
narrowly missed
just look at the damage that was done
from this punch in the background like
it's unreal stuff
he exploded his own fist as you would
expect
his entire wrist and hand was destroyed
in the process
but it grew back just a few seconds
later such is the greatness of this
ability
if you read virginities then you know
what i'm about to say but there's
another quirk he has that he uses even
more frequently
and it's known as overclock i've
explained the overclock quirk a couple
of times in this channel already
so to summarize it in one sentence for
those of you who haven't seen my
previous videos
number six fast this guy in general is
pretty nuts
and he's a puppet of all for one we
don't know the full back story yet
but the implication is that he's some
kind of prototype nomu
with a good level of intelligence now
before we get into the next part of this
list
i'm going to warn you there are big
spoilers from this point forward
so if you want to avoid heavy spoilers
for my academia season 5
then consider this your warning to just
pause the video and check out something
else on the channel
ranked in sixth place we have the
protagonist of major academia
and the future symbol of peace deku i
wish i could have placed him higher on
the list i really do
but being as objective as i can in his
current level in the manga he's not
beating anyone
in the remaining spots at least not in a
1v1 fight
as we all know deku has the one frog
quirk which was passed down to him from
omai
currently he can use it comfortably at
about 30 percent and at a push he can go
up to 45
temporarily this enables him to move at
lightning fast speeds
and generate incredible power with his
various arsenal of smashes
on occasion he's been known to tap into
100 though this is not something that he
can just do whenever he wants
especially as his arms have now just
been totally wrecked up until
this point as far as deku's multiple
quirks go we're currently only aware of
two of them
the nature of one for all meant that as
it was being passed on from person to
person
it stored the quirks of each user within
its core we discovered during the joint
training
arc that deku is the first user of one
for all to gain access
to all of the various abilities one of
which is called black whip
this was a quirk originally possessed by
the fifth holder who was a hero known as
lariat
as you can see the power does live up to
its name as the user can generate a
bunch of black whips from their hand
which is useful for maneuvering in the
air as well as capturing opponents
dragging heavy objects and much much
more black whip
and every other quirk inside one for all
has been building up in strength
alongside one for all itself
so deku essentially has the best version
of blackwhip that there has ever been
his other additional quirk is known as
float although as of recording this
video we've not yet seen him ever use
this power
what we do know is that it's the quirk
of the seventh user
nana shimura who is of course all
might's master and the grandmother of
sugaraki so there's a lot going on there
i hope we get a good look at this power
before the war arc is over
but for now all we can assume is that it
just makes you float in the air
now in fifth place we have nine who was
the main villain of the heroes rising
movie
he is officially canon as we see him in
the manga during my villain academia
so whether or not you think the movie is
canon or not nine himself
definitely is unlike wolfram however
this movie villain does not live up to
his name
as instead of having nine quirks which
is what his name would suggest
he has around six or seven and there's a
bit of confusion on this point
his original quirk was weather
manipulation which he used to great
effect in the movie to electrocute deku
and bakago
not to mention creating a flame tornado
during the final battle
this power let him control the weather
as you'd expect so naturally he can make
it rain and create storms if he chooses
to
nine second quirk is a copy of all for
one which as you all know allows him to
both steal quirks and transfer quirks at
will
for those that haven't seen the movie
when nine scanned people he'd be able to
ascertain their exact quirk
for example when he encountered katsuma
he knew the boy had a cell activation
quirk
for type b blood the editor's words
imply
that this is a part of all for one
alongside the ability to steal and
transfer quirks
but i'm personally not sure if this
translation is 100 accurate
i say that because as it says in the
manga afo didn't even know that his own
feeble brother
had a quirk so yeah just much to think
about but as you can
see that is why it's unclear if this is
actually part of afo
or if it was just a separate quirk nine
also has a barrier quirk that he used
quite a few times during the movie
and it could withstand attacks from deku
at around 20 percent of one for all
these barriers could be laid on top of
each other to provide even stronger
defense
and in fact during the climax of the
movie he made a barrier
with six layers but that still wasn't
enough to stop two users of one for all
of course
in normal circumstances he can use the
barriers not just to repel people like
he did here
but also to blow them away another quirk
of his involves summoning these two
dragons from his back
which move according to his will not
much else to say other than
it's good to have a dragon army on your
side and he mainly uh used them to
restrain his opponents
nine's laser quirk was actually the
first one that we saw when the very
first trailer for this movie came out
it can slice through houses and if the
anime wanted to go dark he would have
obviously been able to one-shot someone
with this
uh but he didn't do so but he could have
done he could have done
last but not least well no actually this
is the least effective quirk
um he has cell activation but the thing
is it doesn't actually work on his own
body
this cell activation quirk was stolen
from katsuma's father
and the person who has it can activate
their cells or someone else's cells
allowing for quick regeneration the
problem is that in nine's case
the quirk doesn't actually work on his
type of blood which is type b
so what that means is that for nine
specifically the quirk is a complete dud
from heroes rising it was clear that
nine was stronger than both deku and
bakugou individually
at least at that point in the timeline
but the power of friendship
i mean one for all was more than enough
to deal with him in the end
oh and shiguraki made sure to decay him
for good measure
next up we have the hyenomu known as
hood who is pretty much what i see in
the corner of my room whenever i have
sleep paralysis
this nomu was made from the corpse of an
underground street fighter
and he's the only high end we've seen
use its full potential
given that the others we've seen didn't
really have much time to stabilize
his first quirk is of course super
regeneration which he used to reform his
entire body
when only his head remained however
perhaps his most unique power
was his transforming arms which did a
ton of damage
during the end of season 4. with this
ability he can manipulate the size of
his arms
and stretch them to ridiculous lens and
even split them into multiple parts as
we can see here
when combined with his muscular
enhancement quirk this was used to slice
a skyscraper
into two parts which is utterly insane
he also has shoulder mounted jets that
allow him to fly
and who would forget the storage quark
that allowed him to harbor several
gnomeus within himself
and then just release them onto the city
below hood is one of the strongest
things we've seen in this series so far
all thanks to the genius of dr garaki
taking the bronze medal on this list is
everyone's favorite hulk
gigantomachia machia was all for one's
loyal bodyguard over the years and he
has a naturally durable body
which meant that he could handle
multiple quirks without getting
remodeled by dr garaki
just to clarify this though because i
know just from reading comments on a
previous video
many people misinterpreted what dr
gracky said here
what the doctor is saying is that machia
was given multiple quirks
it's just that his body didn't have to
be altered in some way to handle them
i seriously had people like trying to
argue with me that he didn't have
multiple quirks one time
and every comment i read my mind was
just like this in one of the more recent
chapters in the manga debbie you know
full-on confirms this
and he says that giganto has a quirk
that transforms morale
into physical energy which is perfect
for someone who is just so enthusiastic
about shigaraki and all for one with
this power he has a really incredible
energy supply
which is why he can fight for an
impressive 48 hours straight
makia's body literally grows in battle
which is why he appears significantly
larger in recent chapters of the war
arc than he did when mina first
encountered him a couple years back
and in fact he even looks bigger than he
did at the start of my villain academia
additionally he has another quirk that
renders him impervious to feeling pain
and a ton more that just help him last
on the battlefield
this is of course without mentioning his
super senses which allow him to smell
shigeraki and track him down
seemingly regardless of how far away he
is there are a bunch of other
miscellaneous abilities related to his
body
such as his powerful breath his natural
durability and his crazy speed
especially for someone of his size
ultimately the guy is just a beast
and he would do anything to protect the
next character on this list
the silver medal goes to the original
symbol of evil and a guy who i
estimate is between 130 to 200 years old
all for one i'm gonna say straight up
that we have no idea
how many quirks this guy has cycled
through throughout the years
so i'm judging him based on what we've
seen naturally his original quirk is all
for one
which we already know what it does so no
need to talk about that a different
quirk that you might not know he has if
you don't read the manga
is life force so this doubles his
lifespan
and causes him to age at a much slower
rate
this is how he's been able to survive
since pretty much the first generation
of quirk users
all the way up to present day society in
my career academia
life force does have a drawback though
which is that the user sacrifices their
physical ability and their athleticism
however we saw during the anime that all
for one has several strength enhancing
and strength multiplying quirks
which likely override this drawback a
younger all for one also possessed a
quirk that let him nuke an
entire island which is how he was able
to kill all might's master
nana shimura as you've seen he also has
a warping quirk that lets him transfer
people
to and from his location or to the
location of someone he's familiar with
but as he said he does need more
practice with this quirk
perhaps one of his most impressive
abilities is air cannon
so this produces a really powerful shock
wave and when it's combined with quirks
like spring-like limbs
it was enough to completely wreck the
surrounding environment
during the big battle look how it
changes the landscape in this moment
from this
to this like that's pretty damn powerful
forcible quirk activation is another
favorite of his
and it lives up to its name pretty well
by activating the quirk of whoever it
stabs
and allowing all for one to control that
quirk this was best seen when all for
one used
on kiragiri and then created portals
based on his own desires
so this kind of shows us that when all
for one uses this quirk he's basically
using people as a puppet when he does
this
the tendrils from the quirk can also be
used to strike other people and just
throw them around
as we see in this hilarious clip as if
all that wasn't enough
he has another quirk which he calls air
walk and it allows him to levitate in
mid-air
though this is very similar to the
description of nana shimura's float
quirk
and it kind of makes you think because
he is the one that killed her and you
know he was there when her when she died
so who knows maybe this is the result of
some experimentation or just
straight up stealing her quirk who knows
all for one also recently stole the
search quirk
which was taken from ragdoll and i think
this one needs a bit more explaining
than the others
ragdoll said in the manga that she has
to lay eyes on someone for this search
quirk to activate
and once that happens the data of that
person is then stored inside the quirk
forever
even when it's passed on to another
person for example
because she used search on deku and a
bunch of other ua students
all for one is now able to track those
students down using the search quirk
essentially the power lets the user
observe and monitor the location
of up to 100 people at a time and you
can know their weaknesses on top of that
we see in the manga that people being
monitored using this quirk
almost look like shining stars in the
distance and when the user is looking
for a specific quirk
the person with that power shines
brighter than the others
the only thing we don't currently know
is how far this power extends like
how far away can you search for someone
afo also has a hypertrophy quirk
which increases the size of his arms i
mean just look at how massive his hand
is here
we see him use this in my academia
vigilantes to attack knuckle duster
and in the main anime he combined it
with a bunch of other abilities such as
bone spear
in a final attempt to kill all might so
with all that said you're probably
wondering who could possibly be in the
number one spot
if a guy like afo isn't and believe me i
have good justification for the order of
this ranking
tomorrow shiguraki is all for one
successor and is the new possessor
of the original all for one quirk his
body has been genetically modified to
such an extent
that dr karaki referred to him as his
masterpiece
think about that the creator of the
higher nomus the usg nomu
and you know obviously he would have
tinkled around with author one himself
over the years
i mean above all of that lie shigaraki
there are two key reasons why i've
ranked him above all for one
firstly his base strength is pretty
comparable to all might
and in chapter 274 this was shown when
shiggy started casually jumping around
like the man himself as far as we know
he has all the quirks that all for one
had you know we've seen him use air
cannon we've seen him use search
so it's fair to assume that all the
other quirks i mentioned all for one
having
shigaraki also has those as well his
decay quirk is now capable
of destroying entire cities with a
single action and his super regeneration
power
puts him just leagues above the reason
afo looked like a potato
is because he never had super
regeneration shigaraki in his prime can
already do that
making him essentially all for one but
with a software upgrade
secondly we've seen in the manga that
shigaraki has inherited the
instincts of all for one himself so this
means that he can easily combine quirks
to suit his knees such as when we saw
him use air cannon
in conjunction with radio waves in order
to disable the hero's communication
systems
because all for one contained these
instincts i mean the learning curve
is not that steep so again at the very
least he's equal to all for one
but in all likelihood you know over time
he will become even more proficient than
the man himself
there's just too much going in chicago's
favor for him not to be ranked number
one on this list
but that is just my opinion let me know
if you're on the same wavelength
i know some people might say you know we
need more feats from shigaraki
but i feel like i mean he's decayed two
different cities at this point
uh and that's without even using all the
tons of other quirks that he has
i just feel like shiggy he is number one
but let me know what you guys think
and if you want to see those two new
episodes of my hero academia
be sure to head on over to
crunchyroll.com to get your two week
free trial
of crunchyroll premium peace out guys